guten Abend und herzlich Willkommen zu
ZDF heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
die Polizei dein Freund und Helfer es
gibt eine neue Studie zu Polizeigewalt
das war dein Forschungsteam mehr als
3.300 Betroffene befragt und unter
anderem auch mit Polizeikräften
Richterinnen und Richtern und
Opferberatungsstellen gesprochen es ging
um die Fälle an sich aber eben auch um
die juristische Aufarbeitung und so viel
kann ich vielleicht schon mal verraten
da passiert echt wenig keine Chance bei
Polizeigewalt darüber wollen wir heute
diskutieren mit dem Kriminologen Tobias
singlestein er hat an dem
Forschungsprojekt maßgeblich
mitgearbeitet und mit Manuel Ostermann
von der Bundespolizei Gewerkschaft wir
möchten die Diskussion gerne mit euch
gemeinsam führen deshalb gerne her mit
euren Fragen und mit euren Kommentaren
die könnt ihr gerne einfach in die Chats
schreiben oder ihr schickt uns eine
e-Mail ja
bevor wir zu unseren Gästen kommen lasst
uns einen Blick auf diese Studie werfen
Julia Schröter die wichtigsten Punkte
zusammengefasst
übermäßiger Einsatz polizeilicher Gewalt
das passiert besonders häufig bei
Großveranstaltungen Demos zum Beispiel
aber auch bei Personenkontrollen die
eskalieren die Betroffenen in der Studie
sind mit 72% überwiegend männlich und im
Schnitt 25,9 Jahre alt auch die Beamten
die Gewalt ausüben waren laut dem
Befragten meist männlich und ebenfalls
jung bis 30 Jahre
bei den Formen der Gewalt sind Schläge
und Stöße am häufigsten bei
Großveranstaltungen spielen Pfefferspray
und Wasserwerfer eine erhebliche Rolle
auch psychische Folgen gibt es zum
Beispiel werden Ohnmachtsgefühle genannt
und ein Vertrauensverlust in Polizei und
Staat
trotzdem erstattet laut der Untersuchung
nur ein geringer Teil der Betroffenen
Anzeige nur
9%, die große Mehrheit verzichtete
insbesondere die mangelnden
Erfolgsaussichten schreckten ab und
tatsächlich wurden 2021 mehr als 90
Prozent der Strafverfahren mangels
hinreichenden Tatverdachts eingestellt
[Musik]
guten Abend Tobias Single stellen und
Manuel Ostermann
schönen guten Abend guten Abend Herr
singelstein ich würde gerne mit ihnen
anfangen sie haben
3.300 Betroffene befragt sie und ihr
Team ich habe es eingangs gesagt was ist
für die Betroffenen am schlimmsten wenn
sie Gewalt durch die Polizei erleben
ich glaube man muss sich zunächst mal
klar machen dass so eine
gewaltserfahrung immer sehr
einschneidendes Erlebnis ist eine
drastische Erfahrung für die Betroffenen
also schon diese Situation des
überwältigt werdens übrigens egal ob
sich die polizeiliche Gewalt im
Nachhinein als rechtmäßig oder als
rechtswidrig herausstellt
und mit dieser Erfahrung mit diesem
Erleben gehen die Betroffenen dann unter
Umständen in den Versuch der
Aufarbeitung und da das sehen wir in
unserer Forschung ganz gut haben sie
sehr schlechte Chancen eigentlich ihre
Sichtweise auf das Geschehen zur Geltung
zu bringen ja und was man sich auch vor
Augen führen muss sind die Verletzungen
die körperlichen Folgen wir haben es
gerade schon in den Beitrag gehört was
uns überrascht hat ist dass wir ein
relativ großen Anteil auch Betroffener
hatten in der Befragung die schwere
Verletzung davon getragen haben 19% der
Befragten haben gesagt sie haben also
Knochenbrüche innere Verletzung oder
ähnlich schwere Verletzungen davon
getragen
damit wir uns das besser vorstellen
können würde ich da gerne direkt
nachhaken was sind das für Situationen
in denen es zu solchen Gewaltszenen
kommt vielleicht können sie da ein zwei
Beispiele nennen
in der Studie haben wir insbesondere
Großveranstaltungen also viele Befragte
die sich beteiligt haben
waren auf Großveranstaltungen
Demonstrationen politische Aktionen oder
Fußballfan Geschehen im Bereich des
Profifußballs spielen auch eine große
Rolle und berichten davon von solchen
Erfahrungen und daneben gibt es einen
Anteil von ungefähr 20% unserer
Befragten die das in so alltäglichen
Einsatzsituationen erlebt haben
außerhalb von Großveranstaltungen wo
also die Beamten wegen eines Konflikts
gerufen werden oder wo die Beamten
selber eine Maßnahme durchführen wollen
Herr Ostermann also halten wir mal fest
der oder die Betroffene empfindet die
Gewalt als
übertrieben
überzogen für den Polizeibeamten ist sie
aber offensichtlich in der Situation
dann berechtigt wenn derjenige sich im
Recht fühlt warum verlaufen dann so
viele Fälle im Sande also zunächst
einmal ist ja die zwangsausübung von
einem Polizeibeamten also Polizeigewalt
gesetzlich legitimiert und ausdrücklich
ist die Polizei auch dazu befugt dieses
Instrument anzuwenden weil sie das
Gewalt Monopol des Staates nun mal
ausübt und wenn Verfahren nicht
beanzeigt werden also das
rechtstaatliche Verfahren nicht bemüht
wird dann ist es natürlich vollkommen
klar dass solche verfahrensausgänge nun
mal ins Leere laufen weil es schlicht
und ergreifen kein Verfahren gibt und
wir haben viele Beispiele die beweisen
dass wir in einem sehr gut
funktionierenden Rechtsstaat leben und
die Polizei das müssen sie auch wissen
dokumentiert ihre Vorgehensweise mit
sogenannten vor zwangsnummern das ist
für jedermann ersichtlich und wenn ein
Strafverteidiger den Sachverhalt
anfordert wird das auch transparent
gemacht insofern ist die Kritik so
pauschal überhaupt gar nicht angebracht
und wir müssen auch kritisch auf die
drei über 3300 Betroffenen Befragten
blicken weil nach welchem Maßstäben gibt
es Vorgangsnummern sind das wahllos
ausgewählte in völliger Anonymisierung
insofern glaube ich haben wir kein
transparenzproblem und das
rechtsstaatliche Verfahren funktioniert
ich denke hier wird etwas dramatisiert
was Folgen schwer ist was so einfach
schlicht und ergreifen nicht richtig ist
also Julian würde ihn auf Youtube da
direkt widersprechen der schreibt eine
lückenlose Dokumentationspflicht würde
schon mal extrem helfen dass man sich
dagegen sehr zeigt dass illegale Polizei
Gewalt Methodik hat was antworten Sie
ihm
jede polizeiliche Zwangsmaßnahme wird
mit einer Vorgangsnummer dokumentiert
zudem haben wir ja auch im Bereich der
Digitalisierung mit dem bodycams und
auch gerade bei Großveranstaltungen mit
dem Beweis und dokumentationstruppen
immer das Videomaterial zur Verfügung
die Polizei ist natürlich dazu
verpflichtet im Rahmen des
rechtsstaatlichen verfahrensaufklärung
zu betreiben gegenüber der
Staatsanwaltschaft und später
entscheidet natürlich ein Gericht
darüber ob hier eine strafbare Handlung
vollzogen worden ist und ich sage es
noch mal ein Strafverteidiger kann eine
Vorgangsnummer bei der zuständigen
Polizei immer Anfragen es ist schlicht
und ergreifend Gegenstand der Realität
das Zwangsmaßnahmen der Polizei
dokumentiert werden in den jeweiligen
Systemen der Landes und der
Bundespolizei
singenstein sehen Sie das durch ihre
Studie belegt Wasser außer man da gerade
schildert
nein man muss leider sagen dass das
Gegenteil der Fall ist wir beginnen mal
bei der bei dem Befugnis in der Polizei
wir haben zwar schon in dem Beitrag
gehört die Polizei kann darf und soll in
bestimmten Situationen natürlich Gewalt
einsetzen um polizeiliche Maßnahmen
durchzusetzen aber es ist eben auch für
die Polizei eine Ausnahme Befugnis das
heißt die Polizei darf Gewalt nur
anwenden wenn gar kein anderer Weg
funktioniert hat ja es ist das letzte
Mittel und die Gewalt darf dann auch nur
so lange und so intensiv eingesetzt
werden wie es unbedingt nötig ist um die
polizeiliche Maßnahme durchzusetzen und
wenn diese Grenzen überschritten werden
dann ist diese Gewaltanwendung eben
rechtswidrig und in der Regel auch eine
strafbare Körperverletzung Amt nun
müssen wir uns klar machen die Polizei
wendet unmittelbaren Zwang oder Gewalt
ja jeden Tag hundertfach tausendfach an
in Deutschland und es würde er einen
Wunder grenzen wenn es dann nicht auch
zu Fehlern zu Grenzüberschreitung und
nicht auch zu Missbrauch kommen würde
das ist sozusagen in dieser
gewaltbefugnis angelegt ja wenn wir
sagen wir brauchen diese Organisation
die Gewalt anwenden soll dann kaufen wir
uns als Gesellschaft damit auch ein dass
diese Befugnis missbraucht wird das
Grenzen überschritten werden
die nächste Frage ist dann wie gehen wir
eigentlich mit dem Problem um also gibt
es gesellschaftliche Foren gibt es
Möglichkeiten das aufzuarbeiten und in
Deutschland ist es so dass in der Praxis
leider wirklich das Strafverfahren das
Hauptforum ist wo wir uns mit solchen
Vorwürfen auseinandersetzen ich glaube
das ist gar kein besonders gut
geeignetes Forum ist aber wir sehen
jedenfalls dass es in der Praxis nicht
sehr gut funktioniert insbesondere haben
wir häufig eine schwierige
Beweissituation stehen also Aussage und
Aussage
gegenüber und es ist für die Betroffenen
sehr sehr schwierig ihre Sichtweise auf
das Geschehen zur Geltung zu bringen und
ich meine es mag für ein Ostermann
vielleicht einfach sein sich
irgendwelche Vorgangsnummern anzugucken
aber wir wissen in Deutschland noch
nicht mal wie häufig und in welchen
Situationen die Polizei überhaupt Gewalt
anwendet weil es wird überhaupt nicht
statistisch erfasst wie häufig von der
Polizei unmittelbarer Zwang egal ob
rechtswidrig oder rechtmäßig angewendet
wird das heißt wir haben überhaupt keine
Datengrundlage um das Thema Polizei
welche Gewaltausübung angemessen
diskutieren zu können noch weitergehen
könnte man sagen selbst Todesfälle im
Kontext von Polizei Einsätzen werden
nicht in der Form statistisch erfasst
das ist für die Gesellschaft transparent
nachvollziehbar wäre wo und wie
polizeiliche Gewalt in dieser Form auch
Auswirkungen so konkrete Auswirkungen
hat und zu guter Letzt die Gesetze die
rechtlichen Grundlagen die die Vorgaben
für die Polizei machen wann sie Gewalt
einsetzen darf die sind ja relativ
abstrakt ne da steht da darf einfache
körperliche Gewalt angewendet werden
oder auch Hilfsmittel wie Schlagstock
Pfefferspray oder eben auch Wasserwerfer
und Schusswaffen aber welche konkreten
Techniken dabei angewendet werden wir
haben ja in den vergangenen Wochen viel
über schmerzgriffe diskutiert und
gesprochen die sind da nicht geregelt
sondern das ist im Prinzip der
polizeilichen Ausbildung der
polizeilichen Praxis überlassen welche
Techniken da als zulässig angesehen
werden und welche nicht
auf diese Aufarbeitung würde ich gerne
später noch mal zu sprechen kommen am
sie haben das eingangs auch schon mal
gesagt und ich will es noch mal am
korrekter Weise noch mal wiederholen
dass wir uns das noch mal vor Augen
führen das was die Betroffenen in der
Studie als Gewalt definieren dass
handelt sich nicht zwangsläufig um
Situationen die sich dann auch außerhalb
des rechts befinden kürzlich ging ein
Video vom MDR viral da geht es nämlich
auch um die Mittel die die Polizei
anwendet es geht um eine Demo der selbst
ernannten letzten Generationen in Berlin
das war immer april und an dieser Stelle
vielleicht eine trägerwarnung finde ich
nicht unwichtig ihr seht jetzt wie ein
Polizist eine Gewaltanwendung zuerst
androht dann kündigt er sie an und dann
zieht er sie durch
ziehen
haben sie mich einmal
Herr Ostermann dieser schmerzgriff der
da angewendet wird der scheint ja
mittlerweile gängig zu sein bei
Demonstrationen die Demonstrierenden
sagen dass es Folter
ich kenne dieses Video natürlich ich
habe dazu auch schon Stellung bezogen
und natürlich auch zu diesem absurden
absurden foltervorwurf die Polizei
handelt nach Recht und Gesetz hatte ich
ja schon gesagt hier ist die
Verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung bei
zwangsanwendung im ausschlaggebend und
der Kollege der hier in dem Video zu
sehen war hat die Maßnahme angekündigt
er wird vorher auch angekündigt haben
den die Ehrlichkeit zu verlassen die
Person hat sich geweigert im Rahmen der
Verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung sich ja
absolut auch kein Verstoß im ersten
Angriff zudem hat sich die Person in
weiteren Verlauf der polizeilichen
Maßnahme durch Sperren ähm entziehen
wollen und diese sogenannten
schmerzgriffe sind polizeilich geschulte
Hebetechniken die eben dazu führen dass
polizeiliche Ziel zu erreichen und wenn
man kooperativ ist und ent eine platt
sofort verlässt oder aber der Polizei
voll geleistet wird diese Maßnahme auch
sofort unterbrochen und ich sage es
nochmal weder meine Person noch
Journalisten Professoren oder sonst wer
hat über die Rechtmäßigkeit zu
entscheiden sondern das hat ein
unabhängiges deutsches Gericht zu tun
und das wird auch aufgeklärt und auch
hier funktioniert das rechtsstaatliche
Verfahren aber ich muss mich und will
mich und werde mich hier auch schützen
vor die Kolleginnen und Kollegen stellen
wir müssen den gesamt Sachverhalt
betrachten und da werden wir auch in
diesem Video feststellen dass die Person
sich massiv sperrt insofern gehört es zu
weit dazu dass wir das komplett
begutachten müssen und nicht nur wie er
Einbahnstraße insofern sehe ich hier
persönlich aus Polizei taktischer Sicht
kein Verstoß und die rechtliche
Aufarbeitung entscheidet zum Schluss ein
Gericht und das ist auch genau richtig
so es geht uns auch nicht darum die
Polizei an den Pranger zu stellen es
geht darum zu verstehen was in solchen
Situationen da passiert und was eben
angemessen ist er singenstein die
Situation die wir gerade gesehen haben
wie würden Sie die einschätzen haben die
haben sie die als angemessen empfunden
also ich glaube man kann erstmal vorweg
schicken dass dass diese schmerzgriffe
so so wird es ja bezeichnet in der
rechtswissenschaftlichen Debatte sehr
umstritten sind und das insbesondere in
der Rechtswissenschaft diskutiert wird
ob sich das um Folter oder
unmenschliche Behandlung handelt also da
gibt es Dissertation darüber ist also
nicht irgendein Hirngespinst wie Herr
Ostermann offensichtlich meint sondern
das ist eine ernsthafte
wissenschaftliche Debatte die da die
darüber geführt wird diese Techniken
sind in der Anwendung ziemlich
anspruchsvoll und sie wirken sich bei
unterschiedlichen Menschen auch sehr
unterschiedlich aus und können dann auch
schwere Folgen haben also wenn man sich
mal vergegenwärtigt dass hier in der
Androgen auch gesagt wird dass es mehr
tägige Schmerzen zur Folge haben kann
also sieht man schon was für eine
Intensität diese Eingriff hat das muss
man glaube ich mal grundsätzlich vorweg
schicken zweitens muss man glaube ich
sagen über die Rechtmäßigkeit einer
Maßnahme entscheiden tut vielleicht am
Ende die Justiz aber selbstverständlich
können alle anderen Menschen sich an
Diskussionen die Rechtmäßigkeit oder
Angemessenheit polizeilicher Maßnahmen
beteiligen ist im demokratischen
Rechtsstaat übrigens eine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass das in der
gesellschaftlichen Debatte stattfindet
und ich nehme als als Jurist der an der
Universität recht unterrichtet durchaus
für mich in Anspruch solche Maßnahmen
rechtlich zu beurteilen wenn uns die
Situation angucken diese Sitzblockade
muss man vielleicht noch mal daran
erinnern die Polizei darf Gewalt nur so
weit einsetzen wie es unbedingt nötig
ist und sie muss das mildeste Mittel
wählen und bei friedlichen Sitzblockaden
ist das mildeste Mittel nun mal in der
Regel das wegtragen das heißt da kommen
zwei Beamte Haken unter und tragen die
Person Weg das ist auch schon
unmittelbarer Zwang aber der ist wenn es
keine Versammlung ist
zulässig wenn die Straße geräumt wird um
eben diese polizeiliche Maßnahme
durchzusetzen und erst wenn überhaupt
wenn Widerstandshandlung sind weitere
Handlungen dazu kommen würden dann
könnte man darüber nachdenken
weitergehen diese Maßnahmen zulässig
sind und das heißt wenn wir eine
friedliche Sitzblockade haben ist eine
Schmerzzufügung ein schmerzgriff der
mehrtägige Schmerzen verursacht in jedem
Fall unverhältnismäßig weil er eben
nicht das mildeste Mittel ist und das ja
Ostermann bitte ich möchte da
Segelschein widersprechen und zwar
erstens ist die Polizei eine lernende
Organisation das heißt also aus- und
fortbildungskonzepte im Rahmen der
Einsatz Taktiken werden evaluiert sie
werden natürlich auch mit
wissenschaftlichen Begleitungen
evaluiert sie werden auch aus
polizeiärztlicher Sicht evaluiert also
heißen die lernen in der Organisation
bleibt nicht auf einem Status Quo
sondern sucht schon Einsatztaktiken die
effizient effektiv sind und möglichst
wenig Schaden bei den polizeilichen
gegenüber Anrichten das zum einen zum
anderen und das muss man auch sehen wir
haben hier einen kleinen Videoausschnitt
wir wissen die vorangegangenen Maßnahmen
nicht wir wissen nicht wie sich die
Person Verhalten das gehört auch zu weit
dazu und zu guter Letzt ist noch mal
fest zu halten dass die Person sich der
polizeilichen Maßnahme durch Sperren
entzogen hat das ist noch mal ein ganz
wichtiger Baustein und damit das auch
klar wird dass man darüber debattiert ob
eine Maßnahme im gesellschaftlichen
Kontext angemessen ist stelle ich gar
nicht in Abrede was ich aber ein Abrede
Stelle ist ein Polizeibeamten der Folter
zu besichtigen wo man gar keine
Grundkenntnisse über den Sachverhalt in
Gänze hat wo man überhaupt keine
Grundkenntnisse über polizeiliche
zwangsanwendung in der gelerntentheorie
und in der gelernten Praxis hat und wo
später dann ein Gericht entscheidet das
ist genau der Punkt wir müssen
vorsichtig sein mit zu pauschalen
diskreditierungen wir wünschen uns das
auf der einen Seite nicht dann verbitte
ich mir das auch auf der anderen Seite
und nur darum geht es eine
gesellschaftliche Debatte zu führen über
polizeiliche Maßnahmen würde niemals
jemanden Abrede stellen ist auch richtig
dass man kritisch auf die Polizei blickt
aber bitte im Rahmen der
Verhältnismäßigkeit und Objektivität ich
finde das ist zwingende Voraussetzung
für eine ehrliche und sachgerechte
Debatte und in diesem Fall gibt es ja
auch juristischer Aufarbeitung die ist
noch nicht abgeschlossen da werden wir
dann demnächst sehen wie die
Staatsanwaltschaft und gegebenenfalls
Richter oder Richterinnen entscheiden
hier gibt es einen kommentar von Sascha
er schreibt ich kann akzeptieren wenn
Polizisten Gewalt anwenden aber einer
friedlichen Person Schmerzen anzudrohen
das findet er unverhältnismäßig Herr
Ostermann wir lernen aus dieser Studie
die nicht repräsentativ ist das muss man
auch erwähnen dass die Betroffenen meist
männlich sind um die 25 Jahre und die
Polizisten sind auch meist männlich und
unter 30 das ist schon auffallend also
fehlt es diesen Beamten an Erfahrungen
an Ausbildung an der Begleitung
vielleicht durch ältere und erfahrenere
Kollegen dazu gibt es auch einen
Kommentar von Benny the best vielleicht
sollte man ein Großveranstaltungen eher
reifere Beamte einsetzen damit sie eben
nicht auf Leute im gleichen Alter
treffen
das liegt in der Altersstruktur in der
Natur der Sache weil auf
Großveranstaltungen wird die
Bereitschaftspolizei eingesetzt ist eine
sehr junge Organisation weil die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach Ausbildung
oder Studium meistens erst in die
Bereitschaftspolizei integriert werden
insofern ist das nicht verwunderlich
dass bei polizeilichen zwangsanwendungen
gerade auf Großveranstaltung
Demonstration fußballveranstaltungen bei
geschlossenen Einsätzen meist junge
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diejenigen sind
die die zwangsanwendung vollziehen und
auch da muss man gucken gerade bei
Großveranstaltungen sehr dynamische
lagen mit viel auch Gewaltpotenzial aus
der Masse heraus sind Beweis und
dokumentationstrupps da und heutzutage
auch überall von vielen
Veranstaltungsteilnehmern auch die
Kameras insofern ist da eine
Anonymisierung eigentlich kaum noch
gegeben und auch David alles gut
dokumentiert auch im
einsatzverlaufsbericht und jeder
Funkspruch wird zum Beispiel
dokumentiert insofern wenn man Interesse
daran hat Verfahren aufzuklären hat man
auch die Instrumente dazu
ähm die Polizei ist da auch sehr
transparent es muss natürlich auch
begründet sein und auch da muss ich
sagen bei Großveranstaltungen muss man
immer auf den Gesamtkontext blicken
gerade auch bei fußballveranstaltungen
oder anderen Großdemonstration das
vereinzelte Menschen in dieser
Versammlung Gewalt ausüben und die
Polizei ist dafür da das Recht auf
Versammlungsfreiheit zu garantieren und
es gibt sogenannte Schranken wer sich
daran nicht hält der muss natürlich dann
auch mit den rechtsstaatlichen
Konsequenzen leben dafür ist die Polizei
da und ich kenne viele viele
Veranstaltungen wo die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr vorbildlich agieren
sollten es Verfehlungen geben und das
will ich auch keinen Abrede stellen wir
sind ja eine lernende Organisation dann
wird das aber auch aufgeklärt und genau
das ist hier der Punkt insofern
verwundert mich das nicht ähm ich sag
mal das im Zusammenhang mit körperlicher
zwangsanwendung gerade bei
Großveranstaltungen junge Kolleginnen
und Kollegen diejenigen sind die sie
eben anwenden das Licht in der Natur der
Sache noch mal weil bei der
Bereitschaftspolizei am meistens junge
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eingesetzt sind
jetzt muss man fairerweise auch dazu
sagen also Polizist oder Polizistin zu
sein ist in den letzten Jahren auch
nicht unbedingt schöner geworden das
gehört zur Wahrheit auch dazu wir haben
hier aktuelle Zahlen des
Bundeskriminalamt zu schauen wir uns mal
kurz an dem nach waren die Beamtinnen
2021 knapp 40.000 mal im Dienst mit
Gewalt konfrontiert diese Zahl steigt
seit Jahren zum Vergleich 2012 waren es
nur
32.355 Fälle also 22,5% weniger
Ostermann in einer Aussage in der Studie
beschreibt ein Polizeibeamter dass es
auch Situationen gibt in denen er selbst
Angst hat Gewalt zu erleben und deshalb
eben agiert was berichten ihre Kollegen
ist das einer der Hauptgründe warum sie
Gewalt anwenden also es sind
unterschiedliche im Einsatzszenarien
diese herausfordernd sind die Polizei
hat natürlich schon aus der Historie bei
unterschiedlichen Veranstaltungen
Erfahrungen sammeln können und
entsprechend auch gefährdungsprognosen
erstellt und so gliedert sich dann auch
das einsatztaktische Konzept auf
selbstverständlich ist es immer wieder
herausfordern physisch um psychisch bei
bestimmten Einsatzlagen
agieren zu müssen aber Credo Maßstab und
Anforderungen auch eigenerwartung der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist immer die
Rechtmäßigkeit der polizeilichen
Maßnahme und die hat nur mal
unterschiedliche Eskalationsstufen aber
und das gehört auch zu weit dazu ähm
heutzutage auch gerade in geschlossenen
Einsatzeinheiten unterwegs zu sein bei
bestimmten demonstrationslagen oder
anderen versammlungsorten ist nicht
unbedingt immer ein Geschenk aber auch
das ist das Schöne an der deutschen
Polizei durch kluge Ausbildungs- und
fortbildungskonzepte und auch interne
psychologische Aufarbeitungen haben wir
da gefestigte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die wissen was sie tun da müssen wir
vertrauen haben und ich sag's noch mal
da wo Maßnahmen nicht in Ordnung sind
wird überprüft im übrigen auch im
dienstrechtlichen Verfahren also
sogenannten Disziplinarverfahren weg vom
von der strafrechtlichen Relevanz und
ich glaube die Polizei sind auch sehr
transparent wir haben überall Beschwerde
stellen auch anonymisiert wir können
auch bei der Staatsanwaltschaft eine
Anzeige erstatten wenn man das möchte
und wenn dann ein Vorgang offenkundig
wird und aktenkundig wird dann wird er
auch aufgeklärt und der Betroffene auch
informiert gerade von den
vertrauensstellen und von der
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit der Polizei
insofern glaube ich können wir sehr
stolz und zufrieden sein eine
großartige rechtsstaatliche und
kompetente Polizei zu haben die steht
zuständig lernt auch aus Fehler ja aber
außer man offensichtlich gibt es ja ein
Problem das zeigt ja die Studie ein
großer Punkt ist ja auch Herr
singenstein dass diese Fälle dann
juristisch wirklich kaum aufgearbeitet
werden woran liegt das
ja ich glaube man sieht es an den
Statements von Herrn Ostermann
eigentlich ganz gut es gibt in der
Polizei eine starke Abwehrreaktion und
eben eigentlich keine Einsicht in das
Problem und das behindert natürlich die
Aufarbeitung solcher Fälle auch massiv
also wenn wenn er sagt alles wird
dokumentiert alles ist festgehalten und
wird transparente herausgegeben kann ich
nur sagen also wirklich das Gegenteil
ist der Fall wir sitzen äh wir sehen in
diesem Verfahren ganz häufig dass es
überhaupt gar keine Sachbeweise gibt und
dass ich die PolizeibeamtInnen die an
den Geschehens Abläufen beteiligt sind
wirklich alles andere als große Mühe
geben zu der Aufklärung beizutragen ich
finde das auch gar nicht wirklich
überraschend und verwunderlich weil da
sind Beschuldigte in dem Strafverfahren
und die versuchen natürlich sich zu
schützen und da gibt es einen starken
sozialen Zusammenhalt in der Polizei und
dass die Kollegen jetzt dann nicht die
Kollegen belasten sondern
das ist eine schwierige soziale
herausfordernde Situation ist und das
ist da dementsprechend
solidarisierungs-effekte
finde ich erstmal ganz normal so dann
haben wir aber die Situation es gibt
eine polizeiliche Berichte ne die
Polizei dokumentiert alles hat der
Ostermann ja schon gesagt das heißt sie
schreibt wenn sowas passiert erstmal im
Nachhinein Bericht und den Schreiben
natürlich Polizeibeamte die an diesen
Geschehen beteiligt gewesen sind und die
schreiben jetzt aber nicht ganz neutral
objektiven Bericht können sie ja gar
nicht weil sie sind ja selber Beteiligte
dieses Geschehen sondern sie schreiben
einen Bericht ähm der der aus ihrer
Sicht subjektiv gefärbt ist weil sie
nehmen das Geschehen aus einer
bestimmten Perspektive war und wie
bewerten uns auch aus einer bestimmten
Perspektive
darüber hinaus werden diese Berichte
teilweise auch genutzt um die
Sachverhalte anders darzustellen als sie
eigentlich gewesen sind in der Polizei
wird es unter den
polizeisch aber heißt das gerade
schreiben also mein schreibt ein
Sachverhalt der vorher krumm war gerade
wenn es vielleicht nicht so schön
gewesen ist dann stellt man es eben im
Bericht ein bisschen anders da und diese
Berichte die sind später in den
folgenden Verfahren eine wichtige
Grundlage für die weitere Aufarbeitung
und können die stark beeinflussen dann
haben wir häufig die Situation dass es
mehrere polizeiliche Zeugen gibt die die
Aussagen weil polizeibeamte sind ja nie
alleine unterwegs sondern immer
mindestens zu zweit oder in der Gruppe
nun ist es so dass die Polizisten für
die ist es ja keine einmalige und eine
neue Erfahrung als Zeugen vor Gericht zu
sein sondern die sind regelmäßig in
Strafverfahren zu Gast und sagen da aus
und deshalb guckt die Justiz auch offene
bestimmte Art und Weise auf diese Zeugen
sie nimmt sie als besonders
professionelle Zeugen war als besonders
glaubwürdige Zeugen und in diesem
Konstellationen wo wir über Verfehlungen
von Kollegen und Kolleginnen sprechen
ist es aber natürlich so dass sie eben
eigentlich keine neutralen
BeobachterInnen des Geschehens sind und
deshalb ähm keine
unvoreingenommenen sondern vielleicht
sogar
problematische Zeugen und all das führt
dazu dass in diesen
aufarbeitungsverfahren die Aufarbeitung
nicht so gut funktioniert wie man sich
das eigentlich theoretisch vorstellt und
das eben die Betroffenen und das ist
wirklich das Kernergebnis unserer Studie
dass die Betroffenen
ist sehr schwer haben ihre Sichtweise
auf das Geschehen ihre Bewertung in
diesem Strafverfahren zur Geltung zu
bringen
also ich kann hier mal ein paar
Kommentare Vorlesen von Nico er schreibt
ich habe mittlerweile wirklich Angst vor
der deutschen Polizei aufgrund der
Erfahrungswerte Simon schreibt hinzu
kommt das Polizistinnen oft mehr
geglaubt wird Julian schreibt niemand
will alle Polizisten über einen Kamm
scheren die Kritik ist dass man intern
nicht aufräumt und sich gegenseitig
deckt Herr Ostermann ist das
Selbstschutz oder falsch verstandener
chorgeist Polizisten ermitteln dann
gegen Polizisten das kann doch
eigentlich vom System ja gar nicht
funktionieren also weder noch zunächst
einmal gibt's natürlich ein
polizeilichen Bericht natürlich verfasst
dieser polizeiliche Bericht auch der
Betroffene Kollege und auch die
jeweiligen Zeugen dann gibt's einen
einsatzverlaufsbericht das macht der
Dienst Vorgesetzte der Vorgang wird
abgegeben an neutrale Stelle die eben
mit dieser Organisationseinheit nicht zu
tun hat wird dann da noch mal im Rahmen
der Qualitätssicherung auf
Maßnahmen überprüft da wird gibt es auch
Rückfragen das wird ab verfügt zur
Staatsanwaltschaft und dann landet es
vor Gericht und vor Gericht hat jeder
die Wahrheit zu sagen auch deutsche
polizeibeamt und das tun sie auch wenn
man sich kurz unterbrechen darf
versingeln Stein hat in seiner Studie
eher festgestellt dass die meisten Fälle
eben nicht vor Gericht landen ja das ist
ja auch richtig das wird daran liegen
dass mangels Beweislage die
Staatsanwaltschaft diesen Vorgang
einstellt das kann ganz unterschiedliche
Gründe haben beziehungsweise wenn ich
sie noch einmal kurz unterbrechen darf
die Betroffenen die Sache eben gar nicht
zur Anzeige bringen weil sie sich im
weil sie auch von Anwälten teilweise
geraten bekommen das bringt nichts lass
es lieber wenn ein Anwalt sagt das
bringt nichts lass es lieber dann ist es
ein ganz schlechter Anwalt dann will ich
nicht normal hingehen könnte vielleicht
auch daran liegen reine Vermutung dass
die Person vielleicht im
rechtschreiblichen aufklärungsverfahren
dann eben auch mit einer Anzeige rechnen
müssen weil das Handeln die die
ursprungshandlung doch nicht so sauber
war insofern muss man da auch genau
hinschauen also zu sagen na ja das
bringt alles nichts deswegen bei Anzeige
ich das nicht ist ein bisschen zu kurz
gedacht ähm ich glaube das muss ein
bisschen allumfassender betrachten und
ich glaube auch nicht dass ein seriöser
rechtsanwalter von abrät das Recht
staatliche Verfahren zu müssen es gibt
doch gar keine sachgrundlage das zu tun
oder muss man den Staatsanwaltschaften
auch vertrauen wir leben in einem recht
statt es steht schon in unserem
Grundgesetz insofern
da muss ich wirklich noch mal einhaken
also bei unserer Studie unsere Studie
sagt einfach wirklich genau das
Gegenteil wir haben ja mit einer ganzen
Reihe von Verteidigern Verteidigern
gesprochen und die haben ja die
Erfahrung gemacht die gehen ja hin in
die Verfahren und und begleiten die und
die sehen dass es einfach in der Praxis
kaum Erfolgsaussichten gibt weil die
Polizei eine so starke definitions macht
hat in diesen Verfahren dass sie im in
der Lage ist ihre deutungsweise des
Geschehens durchzusetzen und das ist für
die Betroffenen unter Umständen sogar
die Gefahr mit sich bringt selber von
einem Strafverfahren betroffen zu sein
und das ist der Grund warum viele
strafverteidigeren Strafverteidiger
davon abraten und das ist ein also
können sie gerne mal losgehen und die
Kollegen fragen und die die werden Ihnen
das unisono durch die Bank wegsagen weil
es eben nicht so schön ist ähm wie sie
es schildern und ich finde es aber ganz
anschaulich dass das jetzt den
Betroffenen mit denen wir gesprochen
haben und den Experten die wir
interviewt haben wieder so ein paar Song
versuchen die glaub Möglichkeit
abzusprechen und das in Zweifel ziehen
und sagen naja man weiß ja gar nicht was
dran ist weil das ist genau die
Erfahrung die die Betroffenen quasi die
ganze Zeit machen und die zu der
sekundären Viktimisierung für die wir in
der Studie dokumentiert haben weil die
Betroffenen sagen ich werde mit meinem
Erleben mit dem Unrecht was ich erfahren
habe werde ich nicht ernst genommen und
unter Umständen werde ich sogar selber
verurteilt während die beamtenbeamten
die sich falsch verhalten haben
freigesprochen werden und das muss nicht
in allen so Fällen so sein aber das ist
auf jeden Fall in viel zu vielen Fällen
so und es zeigt doch dass wir ähm dass
wir dann Problem haben und ich würde mir
wirklich wünschen jetzt ein bisschen
mehr Aufgeschlossenheit geben dazu
dieses Problem auch zu bearbeiten er
Professor sie haben jetzt ein wertvollen
Satz gesagt eigentlich die Betroffenen
haben Angst selber Gegenstand des
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahrens als
Beschuldigte zu sein das darf man nicht
als pauschal Aussage werden dass das
immer der Fall ist aber auch das gehört
zu weit dazu das muss man natürlich auch
berücksichtigen und der kann ich auch
gleich die Gegenfrage stellen wenn Sie
glauben dass sie Staatsanwaltschaft
nicht unabhängig sind was glauben Sie
denn welches Instrument würde wirken
dazu gibt es eine Frage von mobi auf
Youtube neutrale Beschwerdestellen sind
als essentiell für eine transparente und
vertrauensvolle Exekutive warum wird
sich in Deutschland so sehr dagegen
gewährt Herr Ostermann sie sind auch
nicht gerade dafür ne sie haben ja einen
Tweet gab den ich jetzt leider gerade
nicht finde aber da ging es ja im
Prinzip darum dass sie auch gesagt haben
das bringt jetzt nichts und ähm warum
sollte deine extra Stelle eingerichtet
werden ich spreche von einer Stelle
einer Schaffung eines unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten mit exekutiv
Befugnis also in Klammern eine
Paralleljustiz wenn man hingeht und die
Staatsanwaltschaft die Unabhängigkeit
abspricht und gleichzeitig aber
möglicherweise sogar mit
parteipolitischen Interesse beauftragte
installiert mit exekutiv Befugnisse
frage ich mich wo da überhaupt der
Einklang rechtsstaatlicher Grundsätze
ist obwohl er die Vertrauensbasis ist
das entzieht sich jeglicher Kenntnis und
ich habe übrigens gar nichts gegen
Meldestellen die haben die Behörden
sogar auch bei den Landeskriminalämtern
ich will ihn Beispiel nennen ein
polizeibeauftragter des Landes
Nordrhein-Westfalens ohne exekutiv
Befugnisse kann sich jeder daran wenden
klappt ganz wunderbar in Berlin haben
wir jetzt gerade das Problem dass diese
unabhängige
polizeibeauftragte Stelle mit exekutiv
zu Befugnisse eigentlich nur ein
zahnloser Tiger ist weil sie schon aus
Datenschutzrecht den hemnesgründen gar
keine Informationen von der
Staatsanwaltschaft haben darf und ich
glaube wir haben einen super
funktionierenden Rechtsstaat und da
müssen wir darauf vertrauen und ich
glaube es ist falsch eine exekutiv eine
parallel Exekutive quasi zu schaffen mit
der bildungsbefugnisse im Rahmen eines
installierten beauftragten und nochmal
anonymisierte Meldestellen in den
Sicherheitsbehörden gibt es auch in den
Landeskriminalämtern da kann man sich
jederzeit dran wenden das ist kein
Geheimnis und das wird dokumentiert
jeder Sachverhalt und auch jeder
Sachverhalt der nicht beantwortet würde
was nicht der Fall wird auch
dokumentiert wir sind natürlich dafür
aufzuklären aber dann muss es auch
alumfassend berücksichtigt werden und
damit ich drum
Herr Engelstein es ist so einfach also
Ostermann sagt man braucht im Prinzip
auch mehr Personal und dann läuft das
schon
nein also ich glaube die Probleme liegen
ganz woanders also erstens kann man
vielleicht vorab noch mal voran schicken
dass die dass die Betroffenen ganz ganz
überwiegend auch
kein Vertrauen mehr in die Polizei haben
und das Ihnen deshalb auch schwer fällt
zu einer polizeilichen Stelle zu gehen
oder zu einer Stelle die nicht
unabhängig ist und sich dort zu
beschweren oder dort Anzeige zu
erstatten viele wollen auch einfach gar
nichts mit der Polizei in dieser Form zu
tun haben aber ich glaube die Probleme
liegen ja eigentlich auf der Hand und
die liegen auch auf dem Tisch ne in im
Strafverfahren ermittelt die Polizei den
Sachverhalt und das führt in diesen
Verfahren wegen Körperverletzung im Amt
schlicht und einfach dazu dass hier
Kollegen gegen Kollegen ermitteln und
ich glaube dann muss man jetzt ja nicht
in die Glaskugel schauen es liegt doch
auf der Hand dass das menschlich und
sozialen Herausforderungen ist und das
ist schwierig ist und das ist das was
wir auch in unseren Interviews sehen das
ist natürlich eine herausfordernde
Situation ist für für Ermittler wenn auf
einmal Kollegen sitzen gegen diese jetzt
ermitteln sollen ohne ähnliche Situation
ist bei der Staatsanwaltschaft gegeben
bei Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft muss
man sich klar machen die Arbeiten als
Institutionen jeden Tag eng zusammen und
auch an ähnlichen Themen in der
ähnlichen Perspektive wie gesagt die
Polizei ermittelt für die
Staatsanwaltschaft und deshalb ist es so
dass für für die Staatsanwaltschaften
auch Polizeibeamte besondere
Beschuldigte sind keine also die die von
dem normalen Bild was die
Staatsanwaltschaft von Beschuldigten hat
abweicht und deshalb sehen wenn unser
Material gibt es immer wieder
Vorannahmen vorverständnisse mit denen
die Staatsanwaltschaften an diese
Verfahren herangehen also ein bestimmtes
Bild davon von der Polizei von den
Beamten um die es da geht von
Gewaltausübung durch die Polizei aber
auch von den Betroffenen ja und das
führt in der Praxis dazu dass das
Polizisten die in der Glaubwürdigkeit
hier der Justiz relativ weit oben
rangieren in so einer Situation wo
Aussage gegen Aussage steht häufig mehr
geglaubt wird oder jedenfalls gesagt
wird das ich mir nicht aus um darauf
eine Anklageerhebung zu stützen so und
mit dieser Situation gehen andere Länder
ja sehr offen um und sagen das ist
übrigens auch ein Problem der
Gewaltenteilung gehen gehen andere
Länder sehr offen um und sagen wir
schaffen einfach eine andere Behörde
weil es liegt ja auf der Hand das ist
dann Interessenkonflikt gibt und dass
man da vielleicht für ein bisschen mehr
Unabhängigkeit
sorgen kann und richten einfach
eigenständige Behörden ein und sowas
riesig neues ist das jetzt auch nicht
wieder Ostermann ist darstellt wir haben
z.B im Steuerstrafverfahren heute schon
die Situation dass die Finanzbehörden da
die Ermittlung führen und teilweise
sogar Aufgaben der Staatsanwaltschaft
mit erledigen und es würde aus meiner
Sicht überhaupt nichts dagegen sprechen
auch ähm auch für andere Bereiche zum
Beispiel für solche amtsdelikte eine
eigenständige Behörde einzurichten die
sich ja auch mit Polizeibeamten besetzt
ist aber die eben auch mit anderen
Leuten ähm besetzt sein kann die unter
anderem die Betroffenen Perspektive in
den Ermittlungs stärken kann weil das
ist wie gesagt ein zentrales Ergebnis
unserer Forschung das ist für die
Betroffenen sehr schwierig ist ihre
Sichtweise zur Geltung zu bringen
also ich habe das Gefühl sie kommen
heute abend leider nicht zusammen aber
das war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt zu
erwarten ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
für das Gespräch Herr singenstein und
Herr Ostermann natürlich muss man
abschließend sagen wenn die Betroffenen
von Polizei Gewalt das Vertrauen in den
Staat verlieren dann ist niemanden
geholfen und die eben vor allem auch
nicht der Polizei ich wünsche Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend machen es gut vielen
Dank tschüss
vielen dank ihnen auch danke schön
schönen Abend
ja und auch euch herzlichen Dank fürs
zusehen und für eure Beteiligung wir
sehen uns hoffentlich bald wieder ZDF
heute live